A LOT TO UNPEELED HERE IN TERMS
OF THE ONION.
WE WILL HAVE MORE THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW BUT NOW, LET'S TURN TO THE
RADICAL SOCIALIST 2020 DUMPSTER
FIRE WHICH IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
GO FAKE NEWS CNN PROGRAMMING
WELL, IT'S USUALLY PRETTY BAD.
THEY USUALLY HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING A MILLION PEOPLE IN ONE
GIVEN HOUR.
THAT'S PRETTY BAGGED FOR A BIG
CABLE CHANNEL B ILLUSTRATES A
BAY, IT TOOK A FAILURE TO A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
LIKE A TRAIN WRECK, SAD TO
HARDEN LOOK AWAY FROM.
IN CASE YOU ARE ONE OF THE FEW
HUNDRED MILLION AMERICANS THAT
DIDN'T TUNE IN YOUR, SMALL
SAMPLE OF THE THINGS YOU
MIGHT'VE MISSED.
>> WE CAN NO LONGER ALLOW A
WHITE NATIONALIST TO BE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> I CAN TALK TO THOSE WHITE
WOMEN IN THE SUBURBS AND
EXPLAINED TO THEM WHAT WHITE
PRIVILEGE ACTUALLY IS.
THAT WHEN THERE SON IS WALKING
DOWN --
>> WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO START REMOVING THE
CLIMATE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO START MOVING
OUR PEOPLE TO HIGHER GROUND.
>> WHERE THERE BE ANY PLACE FOR
FOSSIL FUELS INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING AND IN OBAMA BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> NO.
WE WOULD WORK IT OUT HERE WE
WILL MAKE SURE IT'S A
LEMONADE --
>> THE FIRST THING I'M GOING TO
DO WHEN I'M PRESIDENT IS I'M
GOING TO CLO ARE CLOROX THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> WE LOST THE STATE OF MICHIGAN
BECAUSE EVERYBODY FROM
REPUBLICANS OR RUSSIANS WERE
TARGETING THE SUPPRESSION OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS.
>> Sean: THAT'S ONLY THE TIP
OF THE DEBATE OF WHAT HAPPEN
HERE.
ODDLY ENOUGH THOUGH WHAT YOU
DIDN'T HEAR DURING TONIGHT'S,
FIVE HOURS OF DEBATES ON FAKE
NEWS CNN WAS THE NAME OF
ROBERT MUELLER.
NOT A SINGLE TIME.
NOW, LOOK, THIS IS THE SAME
NETWORK THAT FOR OVER TWO YEARS,
EVERY SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR OF
EVERY DAY, NONSTOP, BREATHLESS,
HISTORICAL COVERAGE, MUELLER
SPECULATION INCLUDING COVERAGE
EVERY DAY.
NOT ONE WORD.
NOT ONE WORD ABOUT YOU NINE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AT ALL OF THESE DEBATES.
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC BULL, AND OF COURSE
THE MEDIA'S NONDEMOCRATIC PART
CAM, AN EXTENSION OF THE PRESS
OFFICE, IT SEWS SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHING PRESIDENT TRUMP
TAKING.
MUELLER, THAT IF SHE WAS DEAD
GOING IN.
HERE WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THAT A
LONG TIME AGO BUT LET'S NOT LOSE
SIGHT OF A VERY IMPORTANT FACT
THAT WAS CONFIRMED IN LAST
NIGHTS DEBATE.
THERE ARE NO MODERATES RUNNING
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THERE JUST AREN'T.
IT'S RADICAL AND EVEN MORE
RADICAL PURITY GREEN NEW DEAL,
MEDICARE FOR ALL, MAY BE, NO
HEALTH CARE CHOICES.
BUT FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
CANDIDATES ON STAGE HAVE BIG
PLANS FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY.
THIS IS A NEW RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WITHOUT OIL AND GAS TO LIGHT A
LOT OF OUR ECONOMY, IN A MATTER
OF WEEKS, THE AMERICAN DREAM
WILL COLLAPSE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, PROVED THAT
EVEN PRESIDENT OBAMA, AS BAD AS
HE WAS AS PRESIDENT, IS TO
MODERATE FOR THIS NEW SCARY CROP
OF CANDIDATES.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
THE LEFT-WING MEDIA MOB DOESN'T
CARE WHEN DEMOCRATS PUSH THEIR
BASELESS CONSPIRACY THEORIES OR
PROMOTE THEIR WILD SOCIALIST
POLICIES OR PAL AROUND WITH
BIGOTS AND THEY DON'T SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT ANTI-SEMITES.
BUT CRITICIZING OBAMA?
IF THAT USED TO BE STRICTLY
PROHIBITED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IS IT A SMART STRATEGY TO
ATTACK THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION?
>> I WATCHED ALL NIGHT LONG IN
DISBELIEF, IN DISBELIEF AS
NEARLY EVERYONE OF THEM ON THAT
STAGE WENT AFTER
JOE BIDEN/BARACK OBAMA.
INSANITY.
>> I JUST DON'T FUNDAMENTALLY
GET THE STRATEGY OF GOING AFTER
THE MOST POPULAR DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT IN MODERN MEMORY.
>> BACK OFF OF OBAMA AND HIS
LEGACY.
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS YOU CAN GO
A JOE BIDEN WITHOUT TAKING OUT
BARACK OBAMA.
>> I'M WONDERING WHY PEOPLE WHO
WANT VOTES FROM DEMOCRATS SPEND
ALL LAST NIGHT TRASHING
BARACK OBAMA.
>> AND TRYING TO GO AFTER THE
FRONT RUNNER JOE BIDEN, THEY
WOULD EVEN SACRIFICE TRYING TO